foreign
[Music]
the d23 Expo took place in Anaheim
California for the first time since
2019. one of the key announcements
concerned a whole range of animated
films and series planned for the future
when it comes to the topic of animation
and Disney the in-house Pixar Animation
Studios must of course be mentioned as
Pixar CCO Pete doctor disclosed to the
panel there are currently four projects
scheduled the first is Elemental a movie
announced back in May the content is
about a world full of beings each based
in the four elements of fire water Earth
and air so what happens that a fiery
young woman and a rather laid-back young
man meet and have a lot in common
despite the apparent differences in
character at the time of the
announcement Pixar also directly
provided concept art showing the two
main characters Elemental will be
released in cinemas in the summer of
2023 and marks the beginning of Pixar's
upcoming projects second we can look
forward to a Disney plus series from
Pixar after a long time namely win or
lose basic is about a softball team one
week before a major championship game
what makes it special is that each
episode takes place on one day instead
week before the game so you can expect a
narrative without Big Time jumps in
addition the main character changes with
each episode allowing viewers to follow
the turbulent preparations for the
important game from different angles the
premiere is planned for fall 2023 Elio
in contrast is a Pixar project of which
no details have been given before
director Adrian Molina and producer Mary
Alice Trump announced that the film
revolves around the 11 year old Elio he
is artistically talented but has trouble
getting out of the house and making
friends through a secret project of his
mother he eventually comes into contact
with aliens who mistake the
insignificant boy for Earth's very
official Ambassador the movie will be
released in Spring 2024 the last
remaining sequel is to inside out from
2015 as CCO doctor announced main
character Riley has grown up to be a
teenager by now and has to struggle with
whole new emotions that need to be dealt
with Pixar is targeting a summer 2024
release Pixar's counterpart Disney
Animation which excels in frequent fairy
tale references and handmade animation
also and plenty of new projects to
announce their zootopia Plus for example
a string of different short stories
about the most relevant characters from
the film zootopia The release is already
slated for this November on Thanksgiving
this year animation fans can also look
forward to the movie Strange World a
first trailer already provided us with a
sneak peek at the clades a family of
explorers who must overcome a variety of
challenges together in an unfamiliar
landscape in 2023 the schedule continues
with iwaju this is a Disney plus series
set in Nigeria and centers on the
aristola and the poor boy Cole likewise
anticipated in 2023 is wish a film based
on the kingdom of roses a place where
wishes come true solely Asha is able to
perceive darkness in the kingdom and in
her desperation she turns to a star
which eventually shows up for live
action movies did not fall short on the
Disney panel either the next feature is
Hocus Pocus 2 and is scheduled for
release on Disney Plus on September 30th
it will be followed on November 24th
also on Disney plus by disenchanted the
sequel to the 2007 movie Enchanted there
was also a first teaser for Indiana
Jones 5. it is said to be quite
action-packed and show fast-paced fights
reminiscent of the old Parts actor
Jonathan Kee Kwan was also cast again
back then he played the role of shorty
in Indiana Jones in the Temple of Doom
the official Title by the way has still
not been revealed which means that we
can keep on guessing recently there have
been further rumors about the return of
Karen Allen as Miriam Ravenwood who even
became indie's wife after the last part
fans of Avatar 2 the way of water were
also treated to a pleasant surprise as
not only were those attending allowed to
talk to James Cameron about his new film
but they're also given the chance to
watch never before seen Clips with 3D
glasses the theatrical release of Avatar
the way of water is on December 16 2022
in 2023 Disney fans can look forward to
Peter Pan and Wendy Haunted Mansion and
the Little Mermaid to name but a few the
latter in particular has long been a
topic of discussion among movie fans as
not everyone is happy with the casting
of the fairy tale adaptation by Hans
Christian Anderson at least at the d23
Expo main actress Hallie Bailey was
warmly welcomed on stage in 2024 the
influx of new Disney projects is not
going to be any less either with
projects such as Mufasa The Lion King
and Snow White on the schedule
last week selected d23 attendees were
treated to the first moving images from
the upcoming MCU movie the Marvels
following the introduction of Monica
Rambo in one Division and Kamala Khan
and Ms Marvel the two will soon be
reunited with Carol Danvers AKA Captain
Marvel in the presence of the three
actresses and Kevin feige they presented
the first trailer which we'll now
summarize for you based on the
eyewitness accounts right at the
beginning a surprise guest shows up
namely none other than Nick Fury Furious
supervising Rambo during a spacewalk
when she suddenly switches places with
Kamala Khan neither Fury or Rambo know
what is going on this is followed by a
lengthy showing of the post-credits
scene from Ms Marvel eventually Rambo
and Khan meet again whereupon Ms Marvel
tries to use her superpowers for test
purposes again suddenly swapping places
with her friend the two ruminate on why
when using their powers they seem to
randomly swap places no matter where
they are at the end of the trailer Carol
joins them and the three of them fight
against soldiers that strongly remind of
the cree from Captain Marvel finally the
three main characters are shown joking
with each other which gives the film a
rather humorous touch in addition there
are rumors regarding the villain of the
film According to some media reports
zawei Ashton could embody the main
villain Hala in the comics she is one of
the last Cree survivors and even the
Lone Survivor of the accuser Corps
although this has not yet been confirmed
it is still one of the more feasible
theories the theatrical release of the
Marvels is planned for July 28 2023
Disney did not miss the opportunity to
announce news about the second season of
Loki at the recent d23 Expo in addition
to the new cast member Jonathan Ki Kwan
who is known as shorty from Indiana
Jones in the Temple of Doom those
present were also treated to a first
trailer the short clip shows the main
character Loki limping down a long
hallway along with unsettling music a
voiceover can be heard in which he says
that he was pulled through time and saw
Terrible Things moreover not only TVA
but the entire universe would be facing
complete destruction after the events of
the first season he and Mobius reunite
however it is obvious that Loki has
definitely ended up in another world
where no one recognizes him in the
meantime Sylvia is seen in a living room
she apparently has not yet found inner
peace after killing he who remains she
also seems to have no memory of Loki so
it is unclear when the two will meet
again recent Edition Jonathan Ki Quan
only shows up in a brief scene where he
looks like a TVA employee According to
some reports the trailer May makes a
very creepy impression at times it could
even be mistaken for a horror movie Tom
Hiddleston who was one of the star
guests at the presentation added that
the mainly returning cast will be
exploring a much more dangerous
Multiverse than in the first season
judging by the first trailer description
we are definitely excited to hopefully
see it with our own eyes soon Loki
season two will be released on Disney
Plus in 2023
many are already eagerly awaiting the
upcoming Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania there are good reasons for
this as Kang the mcu's new super villain
will be making his feature film debut a
trailer was also shown for the first
time at the d23 Expo revealing many
details about the upcoming flick which
is why we will now discuss the
eyewitness accounts of those who got to
see the still unpublished trailer
protagonist Scott Lang AKA Ant-Man is
now married to Hope Van Dyne AKA Watt
and lives his life as a successful book
author also Scott's daughter Cassie is
not inactive because thanks to her
technical Talent she has built a
transmitter capable of sending signal
waves into the subatomic world of course
the project goes wrong and so Scott
Cassie hope and also Hank Pym are pulled
into the subatomic realm there they meet
Kang the Conqueror who succeeds in
capturing Cassie using her as leverage
he tasks his father Scott with stealing
something from that subatomic realm at
this point many are unsure exactly what
might be so important that Kang wants it
so badly Scott refuses after which king
reveals very shortly why he's the
perfect new villain in the MCU he easily
knocks the Avenger into a wall Kang also
asked Scott whether he's killed him
before as after all he is an Avenger and
they all blur together after a while so
it seems to be no big deal for Kane the
Conqueror to kill an Avenger we look
forward to seeing the trailer in its
entirety soon and are excited for the
upcoming Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania which is set to hit theaters
on February 17 2023.
when Marvel CEO Kevin feige entered the
stage at the last d23 Expo one thing
became clear there will surely be some
news concerning upcoming MCU movies and
series one by one they presented the MCU
of the coming years which is why we have
prepared an overview for you here for
example there was an exclusive look at
Black Panther 2 wakanda forever you
could see pictures of Angela Bassett as
ramonda as well as a short clip from the
movie after the death of King t'challa
as well as his actor Chadwick Boseman
the kingdom of wakanda has to face many
challenges including raids by other
nations who want to get hold of the
valuable resource vibranium the film is
scheduled to be the next in the MCU and
will be released in theaters on November
11th 2022 in contrast a proper trailer
was shown at the panel of secret
Invasion with Nick Fury at the center
next year's series revolves around the
shield leader who after a long journey
in space discovers a society infiltrated
by Scrolls together with allies like War
Machine he must try to avert the danger
in a Edition Don Cheadle who was present
at the event got us excited about armor
Wars a series that will be shot next
year other series presented include
ironheart Echo and Daredevil Born Again
ironheart offered a brief glimpse of her
armor Echo featured a clip of the
returning Kingpin and Daredevil Born
Again received a short clip which
however comes from She-Hulk and not from
its own series also included
insufficient numbers were other films
from the MCU one of the lesser-known
ones is probably werewolf by night which
will be available on Disney plus and is
shot entirely in black and white a
returnee meanwhile could be seen in
Captain America 4 New World Order there
Anthony Mackey takes on the role as the
new Captain America a somewhat different
superhero team are the Thunderbolts who
celebrate their MCU debut at the end of
phase five the disparate Squad brings
together many dubious characters from
the MCU including Red Guardian from
Black Widow and Sebastian Stan Alias
Bucky from the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier yet he is supposed to be the
most normal one in the suicide squad
like Marvel movie rather disappointing
was the panel of Fantastic Four as there
was no introduction of the cast contrary
to expectations as a small addition
Disney presented a few Novelties to
various theme parks including a new
Thanos figure that will soon be on
display at Disneyland in Anaheim a
concept art impressively demonstrates
how the villain will be seen as king
Thanos at The Avengers campus there in
the future besides the countless movies
and series from the MCU Star Wars was
also provided with a stage first there
is the second season of the bad batch an
animated series and spin-off from the
Clone Wars which will be released on
Disney Plus on January 4th 2023 another
spin-off of the Clone Wars is the series
Star Wars tales of the Jedi which
includes six short films and also
features characters such as the socatero
and Count Dooku Disney presented a first
trailer for the series fan favorite
Ahsoka Tano is additionally getting her
own series of the same name in live
action format just as in the Mandalorian
she will be played by Rosario Dawson
apart from the third season of the
Mandalorian which was also proudly
teased there was news about Skeleton
Crew set in the new Republic era the
series centers on a group of four who
embark on a long journey to get home
actor Jude Law is one of the cast
members thus Disney provided us with a
very Lush presentation on the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and equally on
lucasfilm and Star Wars
the 74th Emmys were awarded in Los
Angeles a few days ago it was clear from
the start that there would probably be
no big surprises as the winners had
either already been determined since the
previous year or were clear favorites
the main winner of the evening was the
25 times nominated Apple series
succession which was able to win in one
of the most important categories namely
best drama also highly successful was
the series Ted lasso from Apple TV plus
which was nominated 20 times and may now
call itself best comedy series HBO's The
White Lotus also received 20 nominations
and in fact the series was able to
convert all its nominations into Awards
best lead actor in drama is Lee Jong Jae
from squid game on the male side and
Zendaya in Euphoria on the female side
also awarded best supporting actor in
drama where Matthew McFadden for
succession and Julia Garner for Ozark
all in all a rather unspectacular award
ceremony the only upset is that Better
Call Saul one of the most celebrated
series of recent years once again walked
away empty-handed the next major awards
ceremony will be the Golden Globes which
will also be held in Los Angeles on
January 9 2023
that's it for the news of the week which
announcement are you looking forward to
the most of course you can find all the
trailers for the MCU and Star Wars on
our Channel and don't forget if you
enjoyed this video please give it a
thumbs up see you next time
[Music]